let's go to our caller from the nine one
eight area code caller from nine one
eight who's there
Benjamin David are you doing hey
Benjamin go ahead and so um sins are
really like a questions I mean I get the
kind of is so let's say twenty twenty
comes around and Bernie wins the
Democratic nomination and he goes
against Trump and he loses wish which I
don't think will happen okay but let's
say it did what would like Plan B like
it are wholly like just like the holy
man himself Bernie won Democratic
nomination and got to trouble any loss
like what would be Plan B after that
well then you've got four more years of
Trump I mean plant plan so plan a was
not letting Trump win in 2016 we're
already on plan B which is defeat Trump
in 2020 if we lose in 2020 but I mean
that's that there is no plan B that's
the this we're trying to execute Plan B
right now which is to get Trump out so I
don't know what you I mean it you got to
wait till the next election right yeah I
don't know a different aspect of the
question but that's that's exactly what
we're trying to avoid yeah no I don't
think you lose against Trump but I'd I
get we're turning away that but it's
more of like welcome that's well like we
say like the left is like that's who's
gonna defeat Trump is Bernie and I'm
more of thinking like what like would be
the course of action at 2020 comes
around
Bernie loses like the progressive ideas
that he you know advocates for it just
didn't hold up to American voters will
get on like what would Plan C be like
would it keep just keep pushing that
message yeah you try to win in 2022 and
in 2024 I don't know I mean this you're
poor you you know your question is in a
sense a very straightforward one but in
a sense it's sort of like a deep
question which is do the progressive
values that are increasingly popular in
the United States like for example a
more equitable economic system health
care for all if if those progressive
values sort of lose at the ballot box it
sounds like you're asking should they be
abandoned to some degree
um I don't think they should be
abandoned for the reason that they're I
just know would be like those are
policies that are gonna like help people
and I would hope that we would keep
fighting for it but it's also like
that's how I would do it and that's how
a lot of people don't like the
progressive side would go about it but
then you have like the Democratic Party
where if that ever happened then they
were just I just think they would just
completely just dismiss all of Bernie's
policies and all of the progressive
agenda you know you might be right and
that would be really dangerous I don't
think that there's any long-term
strategy that is abandoning our values
and pretending to be centrists I just
don't think that that's the way that
over the long term we're going to win
particularly when the American people
are to the left of the legislative
bodies of the House and Senate as it is
so I don't think that's the right path
forward I think we've got to fix the
voting system we've got to fix the
campaign finance system we've got to fix
what's going on with media consolidation
and the way that the propaganda machine
creates this vicious circle so listen if
Bernie wins the primary and loses in
2020 that's horrible but we don't say
let's now be centrist so I think that
that's a mistake yeah yeah I agree all
right thank you for the call really
appreciate it great to hear from you